Salut ! Bienvenue dans ce nouveau Mental Vlog !
C'est toujours une vidéo par jour pendant un an.
Et le jeudi je vous parle un petit peu de ce que je veux.
[dring] Et je vais couper mon téléphone...
Je vous en ai parlé ce samedi qu'aujourd'hui j'avais envie de parler des grandeurs non linéaires.
Ca me fait marrer les grandeurs non linéaires.
Je sais que comme ça, ça ne ressemble pas trop à une blague bien rigolote, mais c'est drôle. Je vous assure qu'on peu rire avec ça.
Le coté vraiment amusant des grandeurs non linéaires, c'est que notre cerveau se le représente très mal.
Déjà d'une manière générale se représenter les grandes quantités, on ne sait pas trop le faire en fait parce que ça ne touche pas à notre réalité,
ça devient tout de suite abstrait quand on parle de millions de particules.
On ne se représente pas en fait ce que c'est qu'un million de choses.
A part un million d'euros...
Et les grandeurs non linéaires ce sont des grandeurs qui montent de façon exponentielle.
Je vous ai donc préparé deux exemples qui sont assez drôle pour mériter d'être dans cette vidéo.
Le premier c'est que vous pouvez aller de la Terre à la Luneavec une feuille de papier.
Avec ça vous pouvez faire le trajet Terre/Lune.
En tout cas vous pouvez couvrir cette distance la.
Le trajet de la Terre à la Lune est de 383 mille et quelques kilomètres.
Et comme je ne le sais pas je vais regarder sur Internet.
Et je n'étais pas loin. C'est 384 403 km.
On est pas à un millier de kilomètre non plus...
On peut en pliant cette feuille, quelques fois, couvrir la distance Terre/Lune.
Il faut savoir qu'il est quand même difficile de plier une feuille de papier plus de huit fois. On va faire le test...
Ah oui c'est clair... 5
Là j'en suis à 6 fois.
Et déjà pour moi ça devient compliqué de le plier plus...
Par contre si vous regardez, on voit qu'en 6 fois ça  a pris une grosse épaisseur.
Alors qu'au tout départ ma feuille de papier elle faisait à peu près 0,1 millimètre.
0,1 millimètre, c'est rien ! Mais une fois que je l'ai plié en deux, ça double, donc ça fait 0,2 mm.
Mais une fois que j'ai replié en deux, ça fait 0,4 millimètre.
Ca double, donc ça fait 0,8 mm.
Donc ça double, ça fait 1,6 cm.
Donc ça double, ça fait 3,2 cm.
Donc ça double, ça fait 6,4 cm.
Et c'est ça !
Si j'arrivai à plier cette feuille de papier 42 fois,
42 fois c'est quand même une grandeur qu'on arrive à se représenter nous, mentalement.
En 42 fois ça ferait 440 000 km environ.
440 000 km environ, c'est-à-dire qu'on toucherait de la Terre, la Lune.
Bon... autant vous dire qu'à force de plier ce serait tout petit comme ça, ce serait comme un cheveu, même plus fin qu'un cheveu au niveau de l'épaisseur
mais on couvrirait la distance en 42 fois !
Un autre exemple qui vient d'un conte, d'une légende, on ne sait pas si c'est vrai ou pas vrai,
c'est l'échiquier de Sissa.
Si si.
L'échiquier de Sissa.
Il ne vaut mieux pas avoir un cheveu sur la langue pour raconter cette histoire...
Zé l'éssiquier...
c'est l'éssiquier de Sissa...
c'est l'échiquier de Chicha...
Non ! C'est l'échiquier de Sissa !
A peu près 3000 ans avant J.-C, le roi Belkib s'ennuyait.
Il s'ennuyait terriblement, et il avait promis une grande récompense, on ne savait pas forcément laquelle,
c'était une énorme récompense, à qui lui proposerait un divertissement digne de son intérêt de roi !
Le sage Sissa, c'est pas beaucoup plus évident à dire...
Le Ch...
[rires]
Je n'y arrive pas !
Le sage Sissa a entendu parlé de ça, entendu parlé de la récompense surtout.
Il va au roi Belkib pour lui présenter le jeu d'échec.
Donc avec un échiquier. Et le jeu d'échec lui a appris le jeu de la guerre.
Le roi Belkib adora ce divertissement, adora ce jeu.
Il se mit à y jouer vraiment. Il se mit à kiffer ça.
Bon... Je ne suis pas sûr que le roi ait dit "je kiffe", mais vous comprenez l'idée.
Et le roi demanda au sage ce qu'il voulait en récompense.
Le sage a dit: "c'est très simple, je ne veux pas grand chose. Je veux que vous remplissiez mon échiquier de grains de riz."
"Et pour ça sur la première case vous mettez un grain de riz. Sur la deuxième vous en mettez deux fois plus que sur la première case.
Sur la troisième, deux fois plus, et à chaque case vous doublez le nombre de grains de riz qui avait sur la case précédente."
Le roi Belkib dit oui. Il n'avait pas vu encore ma vidéo le roi Belkib.
Il ne pouvait pas savoir ce qui allait se passer !
Et bien il a été ruiné, clairement.
Il y a 64 cases sur un échiquier. Donc sur la première case il y a un grain de riz, sur la deuxième il y en a deux,
sur la troisième il y en a quatre, sur la quatrième il y en a huit, etc.
Et si vous faites le calcul, arrivé à la 64ème case, il y aura 2 puissance 63 grains de riz !
Encore une valeurs qu'on a du mal à se représenter mentalement.
2 puissance 63 grains de riz, ça fait 9 milliards de milliards de grains de riz.
Et de ce jour, le sage Sissa se fit appeler Uncle Ben's.
Cette info la n'a pas été vérifiée quand même méfiez vous, c'est pas sûr...
Donc au total sur l'échiquier il y avait 18 milliards de milliard de grains de riz à peu près.
C'est énorme !
Encore une fois je sais qu'on a du mal à se représenter cette valeur.
18 milliards de milliard de grains de riz, c'est à peu près la production mondiale de grains de riz qu'il y aurait sur 1000 années.
Hé !
Malin le sage Sissa !
Voilà, j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu, si c'est le cas pensez à laisser un petit pouce en l'air. Ca montre à tout YouTube que vous aimez cette vidéo.
Pensez surtout à vous abonner à la chaine, ça c'est très important.
Comme ça on s'abonne tous ensemble. Parce qu'il y a 2500 abonnés.
J'ai prévu une grande surprise pour vous, on va se faire un live, tous ensemble durant des heures et des heures. Un apéro live virtuel, chacun chez soi, mais tous ensemble !
Rendez-vous aussi dans les salles pour mon spectacle "Fabien Olicard vous mentalise !", ou les "Hallucinations Collectives" du 28 mars qui auront lieu à Paris.
Et d'ici là rendez-vous demain à 17H pour le prochain Mental Vlog.
Ciao !